die plätze fertig los 12 brille runter
mein gott jetzt wieder julien nicht
julian back nine der studien mensch der
mir immer beim aufbau von der kamera
hilft dieses wird auch immer wann und
heute testen wir schafe süßigkeiten
dankeschönfest tolle intro immer ich
freue mich total dass ich heute video
drehen kann weil ich die letzten wochen
so im umzugsstress bin ja ich bin
umgezogen ich hab schon im letzten video
verraten aber in diesem video kann ich
auch noch mal sagen ich bin umgezogen
ich habe jetzt meine erste eigene
wohnung also sonst habe man begeht
gewohnt und immer so mit partnern so was
zusammen aber nie alleine und jetzt hat
sich geändert
ein lohnniveau genau und bevor ich mit
dem video anfangen möchte ich noch etwas
ansprechen und zwar hatte ich in einem
anderen video gesagt dass ich im
november die ganzen kuriosen feiertage
testen werde das habe ich nicht
geschafft wegen dem umzug arbeit habe
vor im dezember lebt packen video
hochzuladen youtube man nie was los
nein ich hab da einfach wirklich auch
bock drauf und deswegen werde ich im
dezember jeden tag ein feiertag feiern
also ihr werdet das zu sehen ist mit
einfach jeden tag ein video kommen und
wenn ihr november schon kuriosen
feiertage gefällt habt wollte euch ich
freue mich auf dem dezember aber nur
wenn man es einfach nicht geklappt denn
immer warum ziehen und ich habe immer
noch kaum möbel und ja deswegen gibt's
das im dezember und wie immer nicht lang
schnacken neue kopf im nacken wir wollen
jetzt sofort loslegen und ich habe
dieses mal auch nicht so viele
süßigkeiten bestellt weil ich denke dass
auch manchmal viel zu lang ist ich habe
auch nicht so viele schafe süßigkeiten
gefunden muss ich ehrlich sagen ich
waren zwei leben drin und habe eine
sache oder ein paar online bestellt aber
jetzt lasst uns mal probieren womit
fangen wir an ich habe immer so eine
magische kiste an der seite dir gar
nicht seht wir fangen an mit buffalo
wings chips mit chili das schaf
ich kann eigentlich ganz gut scharf
essen ich bin gespannt ob es so schlimm
wird und ich habe auch kein wasser dabei
was soll man ja eh nicht trinken wenn's
shop ist dann muss man ja milch
okay okay das brennt auf der zunge
ich verstehe nicht so ganz den sinn von
scharfen essen weil es tut ja im und b
sind okay aus welchem land kommen wieder
import ist ausführt aus wird kommt kelly
und ich glaube mir auch ist okay kann
man essen ist jetzt aber nicht so geil
was als nächstes dran die kennt
mittlerweile schon fast eigentlich jeder
denke es sind so brezel stücke mit
geschmack mit hanjo geschmack guten
appetit
schmecken süß die schmecken halt
überhaupt nicht schafft ja doch ein
bisschen im nachgang bei den chips war
das so dass das sofort so brandt hat im
mund und das ist überhaupt nicht jetzt
so ein bisschen das bekommt von mir
zwei von 15 toten ich sollte mal
anfangen bewertungen seien zu bauen
ich habe von dieser magna bis heute gern
mal ausprobiert und das hat mir viel
besser geschmeckt das ist okay seid ihr
bereit für das absolut verrückteste was
wir an jemand in ihrem leben gesehen
habt schafe gummibärchen willi bärchen
scharfes vergnügen hat weniger wir
nehmen anrufen um richtig scharfen roth
sieht aus wie ein billiges haribo na mal
gucken schmecken die scharf also sie
sind ein lecker sondern gummibärchen
jetzt schmecke ich langsam die schärfe
aber auch nicht so wirklich hotline gab
es ist vielleicht eine zuletzt scherz
geschenk wenn man jemanden mal ein ski
aus der packung nimmt und so selber
nochmal verpackt dass wir nicht wissen
dass die schafe sind bleibt es dann
nochmals und hört die scharfen
gummibärchen bekommt von mir
gibt es heute nicht so richtig gewehrt
und vor topfit wissen hier kann ich mir
jetzt nicht wirklich vorstellen das ist
super scharf dass mein land würde doch
nichts machen was so hatte und brennt
aber es war die einzige träne schokolade
durch gefunden habt also lässt drei
schöne große stücke sind packen sehen
schon schöner seinem lindt schokolade
schmeckt sehr gut heißt eyed peas bon
jovi lindsay mit einem jahresvorrat eine
spielerisch sehr gut mit wissenschaft
das passt sehr gut zusammen schokolade
mit chili ich weiß das schon länger gibt
aber ich hab's noch nie probiert weil
ich mir dachte so was wird denn die
schmecken aber doch ich glaube alles was
so ein bisschen zeit um und damit das so
seine geschmacksvielfalt ausbreiten kann
chili schokolade und kaffee mein mund
ist wieder klavier soll ja
neutralisieren oder wenn ich bei lasch
bin dann ist auch mal so ein kleines
café becherchen da damit man dran
schnuppern kann aber lasst es so wenn
man balasz reingeht interbrand da wie
echt werk bei diesen ganzen dürften es
riecht alles super geil wenn man es auch
einzeln riecht aber dieser gesamt geruch
jetzt haben wir einen ganz besonderen
gast aus mexiko den ganzen weg hatte
nicht aufgemacht um zu uns zu kommen
vinke swinkels salzstetten gummi schlang
mit zeit sei wann es richtig gut ist
oh mein gott okay wir sind so schnüre
die schon so weit besser drauf haben und
jetzt gibt's eine who
das ist so eine richtige flüssigkeit die
aus mexiko kommen kann ok ich glaube
dass trittin scharf
ich spüre das schon dann nehmen uns mal
so eine richtig schöne weiß aber auch
eklig lecker alles scharf und auch voll
widerliche gummi schlange steigender
wassermelone und sich mit salzig und hat
niemand hunger
das würde ich nicht so empfehlen aber
wer hätte es gedacht gummi schlang mit
salsa was brauchen wir jetzt zum
nachspülen natürlich neutra schafe
totenkopf tschüss die verpackung sagt
doch schon dass man sich essen soll oder
ok guten appetit
auch yahoo lesen scharf es ist aber gut
wenn man das problem hat dass man immer
zu viele chips ist dass man sich so
scharf und dass man übrigens auch ein
essen kann stirbt
okay das letzte ist superklein wirkt
aber sehr sehr gefährlich tomic fireball
kennen die madonna des pakets von
amerika so pries welcome to diese
habanero chips sieht sehr unscheinbar
aus nach dieser rote kugeln letzte
süßigkeit
das ist so scharf dass ein kaugummi
klingt nach supercopa ist das château
mit fireball ihr das fühlt sich wirklich
an wie ein feuerball in deinem mund ist
wichtig ganz nicht okay leute das war
mein lieblings süßigkeit von nichts
dafür tut was haltet ihr von schafen
süßigkeiten und allgemein vorm schlafen
essen es sehr gerne scharf ich kenne
sehr wenig leute die scharf essen also
meine mama ist immer super scharf und
die bild als auch immer aber sonst hätte
ich niemanden keiner max ist das bei
euch anders schreibt es in die
kommentare
ich hoffe wir sehen uns dann das nächste
mal wieder vielleicht kann aus meiner
wohnung vielleicht doch nicht mal gucken
wir sehen uns dann tschüss und bevor ich
vergesse dankeschön für 400.000
abonnenten das ist richtig cool freut
mich vor dass er so viele sind die meine
mädels gucken wollen
und auch immer kleiner werden wollen
dass es neue weges geht man wenn er
wirklich nichts verpassen wollt dann
könnt ihr noch die glocke an machen
wow hier gibt's noch videos das wisst
ihr ja und abonnieren
falls ihr zu diesem 400.000 club gehören
wollte abonnieren
ok ich dass ich werde niemals in meinem
leben wirklich ernsthafte abmoderation
hinkriegen beim groß denn ich bin